here's what would happen if you touched  the Sun  the sun's surface is hotter than  anything you've ever encountered it's  about 1 million degrees Celsius as your  spaceship got close to the Sun you'd be  exposed to massive amounts of radiation  you'd need to slap on tons of the  strongest sunscreen wear sunglasses and  a sun shield in your heat resistant  spacesuit once you arrived at the sun's  surface the Photosphere you wouldn't be  able to land since there's no actual  surface further in at the sun's core  you'd finally reach out and try to touch  sadly for you it's light years Beyond  sizzling you'd be almost instantly  obliterated no material on Earth can  withstand these temperatures the closest  we can get right now is about 1.6  million kilometers away so